TODAY I'M GONNA ANNOUNCE
OFFICIALLY THAT I'LL BE
HOSTING A NEW SHOW FOR
C-SPAN CALLED
"HATEWATCH WITH JON STEWART."
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HERE'S A SNEAK PREVIEW.
>> COMING UP NEXT ON C-SPAN 2
JON STEWART LOOKS AT CONGRESS IN
C-SPAN'S NEW SHOW, "HATEWATCH."
THEN AT 11:30 P.M., ON BOOK TV,
AUTHOR MICHIO KAKU DISCUSSES THE
CHALLENGES OF WRITING A MEMOIR
WHEN THERE'S A BEE TRAPPED IN
YOUR OFFICE.
>> HI, EVERYBODY.
WELCOME TO "HATEWATCH" ON C-SPAN
2, I'M JON STEWART.
WHY DON'T WE TAKE A LOOK TODAY
AND SEE WHAT OUR CONGRESS IS UP
TO?
>> A BIPARTISAN BILL TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS AND ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS GOTTEN
STUCK IN THE SENATE.
>> Jon: MOTHER -- SO IT APPEARS
THE SENATE IS STUCK ON A BILL
I'M SURE EVERY AMERICAN WHO'S
NOT CURRENTLY ACTIVELY INVOLVED
IN TRAFFICKING HUMANS FOR
SEX WOULD SUPPORT.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING I
WOULD HATE.
TELL ME MORE.
>> DEMOCRATS HAD JOINED
REPUBLICANS IN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IN COMMITTEE BUT ARE
NOW FIGHTING TO STRIP
OUT HYDE AMENDMENT LANGUAGE.
>> Jon: AH YES, THE HYDE
AMENDMENT, NAMED FOR THE ACTION
THAT REPUBLICANS APPARENTLY HAVE
TO TAKE TO GET THE ANTI-ABORTION
LANGUAGE INTO ALL BILLS. LET'S
HIDE IT OVER HERE, LET'S HIDE IT
OVER -- THE HYDE AMENDMENT
BLOCKS THE USE OF FEDERAL MONEY
FOR ABORTIONS, BECAUSE JUST
BECAUSE A PROCEDURE IS
COMPLETELY LEGAL DOESN'T MEAN IT
HAS TO BE TREATED THAT WAY.
I SEE WHAT'S HAPPENED, A LITTLE
BIT OF REPUBLICAN WHAT WE AT
C-SPAN TWO CALL (BLEEP)RY.
HOW DID THE SEX TRAFFICKING BILL
GET PASSED COMMITTEE
WITHOUT ANY NOT REPUBLICANS
COMPLAINING.
>> DEMOCRATS DO ADMIT THAT WHEN
THIS BILL WENT THROUGH THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND WAS APPROVED BY BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
THEY DIDN'T READ IT FULLY.
>> Jon: YOU DIDN'T READ IT
FULLY.
WHAT, DID YOU JUST SKIM IT TO
SEE IF YOUR NAME WAS MENTIONED?
MOM!
I'M IN THE BILL!
>> WE DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS IN THE
BILL.
YOU CAN BLAME IT ON STAFF, BLAME
IT ON WHOEVER YOU WANT TO BLAME
IT ON.
>> Jon: HOW ABOUT I BLAME NOT
READING THE BILL ON YOU?
SENATOR HARRY REID, THE GUY IN
CHARGE OF SENATE DEMOCRATS WHOSE
LAST NAME IS LITERALLY" REID ."
HOW DID YOU NOT READ THIS BILL?
IT'D BE LIKE GOING TO JOHN
WATERS' HOUSE AND FINDING OUT
ALL OF HIS PLANTS ARE DEAD.
JOHN, WHY DIDN'T YOU YOUR LAST
NAME THEM!
WELL, IT APPEARS (BLEEP)ERY AND
DUMBASSERY ARE RUNNING NECK
AND NECK TO STYMIE THE HUMAN SEX
TRAFFICKING BILL
EVERYONE AGREES SHOULD BE A LAW.
AS REPRESENTED HERE BY SAID
(BLEEP) AND DUMBASSES.
>> A REPUBLICAN JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE STAFFER SENT A
DEMOCRATIC STAFFER A SUMMARY
OF CHANGES TO THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THE BILL IN SEVEN
BULLET POINTS.
GUESS WHAT.
THEY LEFT OUT THE CHANGE THEY
MADE.
>> REPUBLICANS ANNOUNCING THAT
TRUSTING THEM WAS A MISTAKE.
>> Jon: REALLY? YOU THINK?
YOU THINK THAT TRUSTING THE
REPUBLICANS WAS A MISTAKE
YOU KNOW WHO THAT'S ON?
IT'S THE SAME WAY NOBODY BLAMES
THE BEARS IN "GRIZZLY MAN" FOR
EATING THE DELICIOUS-LOOKING
MEAT SACK WHO KEPT STICKING HIS
HANDS IN THEIR POOP.
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEARS.
YOU KNOW WHAT, PERHAPS
NOW IT'S TIME ON
"HATEWATCH" TO GO TO THE
PHONES.
>> "HATEWATCH" PHONE
CALLS SPONSORED BY ARBY'S.
ARBY'S, BRINGING
WASHINGTON-STYLE GRIDLOCK
TO YOUR COLON.
>> Jon: JUST CALL THE NUMBER
ON YOUR SCREEN, CALL TO GET IN
ON OUR --
(LAUGHTER)
IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE OUR FIRST
CALLER.
NOW OBVIOUSLY SINCE THIS IS
C-SPAN THE CALLER WILL PROBABLY
BE A NON-SCREENED, UNAPOLOGETIC
RACIST. LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
YOU'RE ON THE AIR.
>> Caller: JON, CLEARLY THE
PROBLEM HERE IS BLACK PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE AN AMERICAN WORK
ETHIC AND CAN'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND CIVILIZATION, SO AS
LONG AS PRESIDENT BROKE O'BUMMER
IS IN OFFICE OPPRESSING WHITE
PEOPLE --
>> Jon: OKAY GOODBYE.
LET'S RETURN TO OUR EXAMINATION
OF HOW A BIPARTISAN SEX
TRAFFICKING BILL IS STUCK IN THE
SENATE.
I BELIEVE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
MCCONNELL WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
A DISINGENUOUS POINT.
>> LET'S NOT FILIBUSTER
BIPARTISAN HELP FOR VULNERABLE
VICTIMS JUST TO MAKE A POINT FOR
LEFT-WING SPECIAL INTEREST
GROUPS.
>> Jon: HOW DARE -- THE ONLY
REASON THE LANGUAGE IS IN THERE
IS BECAUSE YOU'RE BOWING DOWN TO
RIGHT-WING SPECIAL INTEREST --
YOU KNOW, SON OF A BITCH!
I WANNA -- LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING!
TURTLE MAN!
I, YOU KNOW WHAT -- I JUST, I
NEED A MOMENT.
I NEED A MOMENT.
>> UP NEXT WE'LL TRAIN OUR
CAMERAS ON AN EMPTY PODIUM LONG
BEFORE ANYONE APPROACHES
IT TO SPEAK.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT. I'M OKAY, I'M
OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
UNLESS SENATOR MCCONNELL IS
ABOUT TO IN THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH OF COMPLAINING THAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE USING AN
UNRELATED ISSUE TO HOLD UP
IMPORTANT SENATE BUSINESS --
HOLD UP IMPORTANT SENATE
BUSINESS WITH AN UNRELATED
ISSUE.
>> SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
MCCONNELL SAYS HE WILL PUT OFF A
CONFIRMATION VOTE ON ATTORNEY
GENERAL NOMINEE LORETTA LYNCH
UNTIL THE SENATE PASSES A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BILL.
>> Jon: YOU'RE DOING THE
SAME THING -- HELP!
HELP! HELP!
>> WE NOW REJOIN LIVE A
REENACTMENT OF A CIVIL WAR
BOOK PANEL.
>> BLAH, BLAH, BLAH GETTYSBURG.
>> OH SO WITTY, NORTH FREEDOM,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
>> LOOK AT MY HAIR, I'M SO
OLD I WEAR A BOW TIE!
>> FASCINATING...
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT. WELL,
IT APPEARS THE FAILURE OF THE
SEX TRAFFICKING BILL TO PASS
THE SENATE WOULD SEAL THE
VICTORY FOR (BLEEP)RY IN THIS
CASE BUT WE WON'T SURE UNTIL THE
VOTE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR ACCOMPANIED BY
CLASSICAL MUSIC TO MAKE YOU FEEL
SMART.
(MUSIC)
>> Jon: ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THIS IS JUST
TAKING TOO LONG.
I'M GONNA MAKE ANOTHER
ANNOUNCEMENT.
SIX AND A HALF MINUTES AGO,
C-SPAN 2 GAVE ME AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO HOST THIS SHOW.
BUT I THINK NOW IT'S TIME FOR
SOMEONE ELSE, ANYONE ELSE.
"HATEWATCH" DOESN'T DESERVE A
HOST WHO'S EVEN SLIGHTLY
NAUSEOUS.
NOW I DON'T KNOW WHEN I'LL BE
LEAVING "HATEWATCH."
OH YES, I DO.
RIGHT (BLEEP) NOW.
WOW!
THAT WAS A NIGHTMARE!